it amazes me that people have
pre-existing notions that defy the
evidence of reality but that they hold
on to them so dearly and one of them is
the notion of creationism or in fact
look Senator Marco Rubio who's
presumably a reasonably intelligent man
and maybe even educated was asked what's
the age of the earth and ultimately
either because he he actually believed
it or he would or he was trying to
appeal to some constituency had to argue
that it's a big mystery that somehow we
should teach kids both ideas that the
earth is 6,000 years old and that it's
4.5 5 billion years old which is what it
is if you think about that somehow
saying that well anything goes we you
know we shouldn't offend religious
beliefs by requiring kids to know to
understand reality that's child abuse
and if you think about it teaching kids
at the or allowing the the notion that
the earth is 6,000 years old to be
promulgated in schools is like teaching
kids that the distance across the United
States is 17 feet that's how big an
error it is now you might say look a lot
of people believe that so don't we owe
it to them to allow their views to be
present in school well as I've often
said the purpose of education is not to
validate ignorance but to overcome it
50% of the people in the United States
when we probe them each year with the
National Science Foundation think that
this that the Sun goes around the earth
not that the earth goes around the Sun
when we ask the question and we provide
the question the earth goes around the
Sun and takes a year to do it
true or false almost every year 50% of
the people get that wrong now does that
mean in schools we should allow the the
anti Galilean and Copernican idea that
the Sun goes around the earth to be
taught absolutely not if in fact
the very fact that people don't know
that and the very fact that it enough
people are willing to somehow believe
the earth is 6,000 years old means we
have to do a better job of teaching
physics and biology not a worse job the
last thing we want to do is water down
the teaching of biology because some
people don't recognize that evolution
happened evolution is the basis of
modern biology and in fact if if a lot
of people don't believe it it only means
we have to do a better job teaching it
so once again I repeat the purpose of
education is not to validate ignorance
but to overcome it and to overcome a
situation where a United States Senator
can speak such manifest nonsense with
impunity is vitally important to that
our society technology and biotechnology
will be the basis of our economic future
and if we allow nonsense to be
promulgated in the schools we do a
disservice to our students a disservice
to our children and we're guaranteeing
that they will fall behind in a
competitive world that depends upon a
skilled workforce able to understand and
manipulate technology and science
you